So, my name is Nikolas Blanchet, I'm 31 years
old, I currently live in San Francisco, California though
I have lived all over the United States and
I am, have been diagnosed with Bipolar II Disorder.
>> And what is Bipolar II Disorder?
>> Bipolar II Disorder is characterized
by long periods of depression-like symptoms.
some, lethargy, lack of motivation, lack
of ambition. periods periods of hopelessness,
periods of sadness. Although not everyone experiences
it in the same way. in addition to
that, bipolar 2 had a fundamental twist where
you've also got periods of what's called hypomania.
>> Mm-hm.
>> hypomania is like a less extreme form
of mania, mania being where you have a
complete break from reality. And you are hyper
energetic, hyper optimistic. you usually take a lot of
risky behavior. For example sort of
the characteristics that my doctor always tells
me to watch out for is give me a call if you decided that
you're going to Vegas and going to buy a yacht for the weekend because
it might seem a lot of fun so bring me in on the fun.
[LAUGH].
>> I see and so you, then you've experienced these symptoms yourself.
>> I have have hypomania. So, what I described was mania. Hypomania
is a less extreme form. And that's one of the reason why bipolar
2 disorder is actually mis characterized and misdiagnosed, which was the case
with me. hypomania, in my case,
manifested as periods of extreme sociability. hypersexuality.
extreme productivity at work. And less sleep than normal. Also
with bipolar II disorder the hypomanic periods are rare, so one
to two times a year, and fairly brief. somewhere between
three and seven days, which is very different than standard mania.
>> I see. And when were you diagnosed?
>> I was diagnosed bipolar II disorder in November of 2012.
>> Ok so you've only known then
for a low little time.
>> Right.
>> And how, how has that affected you.
How how did how how did that come about.
>> So I am I have diagnosed with depression for and this
is apparently by the way a very typical story. I had been diagnosed
with depression for about five years. I was going to psychiatrist and a
psychologist regularly and they would prescribe
various antidepressants, none of which would work.
And, in fact, my symptoms, over time, gradually,
but, but noticeably, trended worse and worse and
worse. after I moved to the Bay Area.
my psychiatrist that I got out here, pointed out
that I might actually not be responding well
to the medication, because it was treating something that
I didn't have. And, instead, he sw-, suggested
that I switch to mood stabilizers. Well, the confirming
fact came after I was taking a very high dosage of an
antidepressant. And through the end of November, and through most of December,
I had a very very bad period of depression. I had no
motivation to do anything. I was very sorry I looked at the camera.
>> No problem.
>> I had a very, very bad period of depression. I had no motivation to do
anything. I stopped going to work. It was
pretty bad. And, then, when I went back and
saw him again. He prescribed a, what's called a
mood stabilizer. Which is different than an anti-depressant. A mood
stabilizer, the most famous of which is, Lithium. They
are also, they're actually the class of drug is, anti-epileptic.
>>
>> And they, they basically cut off the
peaks of bipolar II disorder, which is helpful.
>> Great, so after you started this regimen of
of, of, of drugs then you didn't experience the
depression and the hypomania that you've been experiencing previously.
>> Right. And another thing I want to point
out about bipolar II disorder that makes it so
difficult to to diagnose. Is you don't go to
your, if you think about it, you don't go to
your doctor. And you don't tell your doctor by
the way my arm is not broken, right? You don't
tell him when you're not having a problem. And
when you spend such a long period of your life
in a dark place, in a, in a depressed state. Which is the way bipolar II works.
when you have these brief periods of hypomania, you
feel like that's how your life should always be.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Because it doesn't seem alarming, when it's going
on, and people aren't alarmed by you, because it's
not that complete snap from reality. So, when I
would go to my doctor I never mentioned these periods.
>> Mm-hm.
>> now I don't have them anymore, but
I'm a lot more stable in my day-to-day life.
>> Nice, well that leads me to another question sort of about
advantages and disadvantage here. You've touched on them briefly but from your
own perspective, I mean are there any advantages to being or have
you shown symptoms of bipolar and, and. I'm also curious on the disadvantages.
>> So the advantages I've never really thought of it that
way. one thing they don't tell you is that hypomania is awesome.
[LAUGH]
It feels really good. you're an animal in bed, you are hyper productive
at work. You have a lot of energy, you are really social, you're really
charming, you're really dynamic. you can be a little bit more risky with
your behavior but not so much so the people are like scared for you.
>> mm. So the people just think bad
[INAUDIBLE]
you basically feel like you're king of the world for
a period of time. and so I guess that's an advantage.
>> mm.
>> I guess you can also say there's this philosophical
advantage of knowing what pain is but lets that's just crazy.
>> Right.
>> Which is what I am, so that's okay.
>> the the disadvantages are obviously work disruption,
right? So that's the biggest one. With me
these long, drawn out periods of silence. And you know
as a friend of mine like I would go through
periods where no one would hear from Nick. Where's Nick?
I would just disappear. Because keeping up appearances and making sure
the people around me are comfortable, having a good time,
is important to me. Ans so when I was in a
bad place I, instead of like being the negative guy
around everyone all the time, I just sort of removed myself
from the situation. And of course, there is social stigma and stuff attached
with it too, which makes it complicated.
Makes it difficult to have relationships. Makes
it difficult to stick to tasks. I stopped and started college a number
of times and looking back it probably had a lot to do with this.
>> mm. I don't want to blame this for all of my problems, right? I still
have good days and bad days. I'm still
mortal. I still make mistakes. But I suppose
now that I think about it, another advantage of bi-polar disorder and having had
it diagnosed is I get insight. I know a little bit more about why things
happen why am I this way. Why, why it gives context. It doesn't excuse
things I still have things I need to work on.
But it gives a little context about what my struggles might
be about the things that I need to watch out for.
It also makes sure that I exercise because that's very helpful.
>> In your mind based on the
advantages and disadvantages you've shared with us, if
you could not be bipolar II, would you choose that for yourself at this point.
>> Definitely. this isn't something, this isn't something like being
gay or being or, I don't know, being artistic, or something
Where it might seem like a disadvantage at a period
of time in your life, but then contextually, it, it gets,
you know, better over time, or you're able to socialize it,
or come to peace with it. Even if you come to
peace with being bipolar, which, I'd like to think I have,
but it's pretty quick. It's still early on, I've only, I haven't
even been diagnosed for a year yet. even after coming to
peace with it though, it's not, it's not really something that
is a good thing. I mean, if I have kids, I'm,
I'm a carrier for this, potentially, from what I understand? You're the
geneticist, so you tell me. but, I've got a
huge family history of it. It, it creates, it's
something that you have to disclose when you date,
which is not fun. see, I'd rather not be.
>> Well, so you touched on two points that are really interesting. How do
other people perceive you as someone who
is bipolar? What's the general reaction? How,
how is it perceived by others, just strangers, say the general public, but
also your friends, have they responded,
and what's your reaction to their reactions.
>> When people who I know, and have known for a period of time,
find out that I'm bipolar, I tend to get one of two reactions. One is
generally supportive, in saying oh, well, I'm
glad you're getting this managed, I'm glad you've
got some stuff. And the other one's sort of like Duh, I could have told
you that!
[LAUGH]
Not because it manifested. Because, but because, you know? They're,
because they have noticed these trends that I have. And they
knew that there was something up, but they never knew
what it was. And so, okay, this makes sense that you've
got this. I have, I have been. Let me start
that over. I have also, sort of taken it upon myself
to sort of raise awareness, it's one of the reasons
why I was willing to do this interview. So, I do
actually tell people who I don't know well, and I
admit it earlier on. Admit it sounds like the wrong
word. and I disclose this earlier on rather than later,
because it's not my fault, it's nothing I did, it's
just a trait that I've got! I've got blue eyes,
I've got a slightly crooked nose, I've got a red
beard and red hair. I'm also bipolar. And so it's
just something that I've inherited. And most people that I've noticed
when I tell them
they sort of.
[LAUGH]
The number one reaction I get is that they name
someone else that they know and are close to that is,
that is bipolar 1 or 2. and they immediately look for
some sort of connection. And so my reaction to that, when
people look to try and humanize it and make a
connection with me as I, I don't know, I, I want to
go into detail. It makes me, it makes me feel like
I'm not doing this on my own, if that makes sense.
>> Sure. Are
they really negative reactions? Do people ever, I mean, I
heard you make a joke earlier about, you know, oh,
I'm crazy. do people, are there any misperceptions out there
that you've found about bi-polar, and, and what are this misperceptions?
>> There's, bi-polar II specifically, I've noticed,
also sort of has a. Other people
who have Bipolar II disorder, a lot
of times they've been living with depression or
bipolar II for a very long time undiagnosed. And they've set
a lot of habits in place. And they've come to a
lot of, I feel like not good self image. And a
lot of people that I have met who are bipolarII actually
want to blame everything on the illness. Like they'll say you
know, why would I you know I I told my boss
the other day, well, I"m bipolar so I shouldn't have to
deal with this. And so that it becomes this tug of war
between integration with society, becoming a productive member, and actually
doing what you need to do to, to handle your disability.
>> you mentioned previously too that, you said you
have a family history of this. Now, from a genetics
prospective elucidating the genetic component of bipolar disorder along with
many other mental sort health conditions, anything from schizophrenia
to autism has been very difficult to
identify single genetic cause, even several genetic
causes, and most of the findings have
indicated smaller contributions of individual genes here
and there. The search continues with gelomyrtol
association studies. Now people are trying to
move into whole genom sequencing of people
who have been diagnosed. we're curious to know,
what is your family history of bipolar and any
other mental health condition that you think might be related?
>> My family on my mom's side were crazy.
>>
[LAUGH]
>> Like it's just for real, real. so my
mom, my mom was diagnosed with bipolar II disorder. And
she's, she was actually on the same medication that
I am on now for a while. But she never
told me this. Growing up with a sort, and,
and, and you can read up on this more if
you're interested, but growing up with sort of a, like
a, a, a mentally ill parent causes a lot of,
like you'd react to things slightly differently. Like I keep
my mom at an arm's distance and she sort of felt
embarrassed by stuff, and so there wasn't a lot of
disclosure about the health situations and the, and the traits that
we've got. So I'm only recently finding out a lot
of this stuff that my mom's got. She's also been diagnosed
well, I'm going to caveat this by saying that this is
all reported by my mother. So I actually, obviously, I don't,
I'm not privy to her medical records. But, according to my mother, there are
also depression, and ADD, and And
sometimes, depending on the doctor she sees, a personality disorder like
borderline or something. my sister, one of my younger sisters, suffers
from depression. my dad is the actually,
on that side of the family. He is the most ADD person I
have every met in my entire life. Like, you know, the Wikipedia hole.
Where you just keep clicking on
hyperlink after hyperlink after hyperlink, until you've
got a million tabs open. Yeah, like,
he can't use Wikipedia, because it's paralyzing.
>>
[LAUGH].
>> His, his weekend will be gone.
>> So, it sounds like you have, you
know. Immediate and extended family that have also demonstrated
similar symptoms of depression and possibly even mania
like you say in your, in your mom hypomania.
>> Right.
>> and how does that make you feel
about a connection with other people genetically speaking
and otherwise. Do you feel a kinship with
other people that have been diagnosed with bipolar?
or do you think of these people, as in,
they're just other people, and, happens to be a
trait as well, or is this part of a
broader thread that you think ties you to other people?
>> Well, I definitely think there's shared experience. but the social
stigma against a lot of mental illness, particularly bipolar, too, because
it just sort of looks like laziness a lot of the
time. the social stigma there actually even affects the people who
have it. Right? So, I find myself, when
I'm not, you know, thinking this through, behaving logically,
I find myself not wanting to associate with other
bipolar people, wanting to hold them at arms' distance,
not wanting to find some sort of community.
because what do we have in common? What? We're
all crazy. Why should we celebrate that? This is
a problem, and, yet, that shared experience is helpful.
sometimes you can get insights from very interesting and different
places that you would never think about. So, and about
areas in your life, and managing areas in your life,
like the exercise thing. Exercise has been a huge impact on
my life. And that, I mean, my doctor mentioned it
but it didn't really sink in until I saw the high
functioning people who are bipolar, too, all exercised. But then,
again, maybe I thought they were high functioning because they exercised,
>> sure
>> and I like,
that's what it is for me. I don't know.
>> So when you, you, when you bring that up just the sort of give all of
our students a generally well rounded perspective here.
Are you telling us that bipolar II is manageable?
>> Very manageable. Bipolar II is unlike some other mental
illnesses. bipolar II is it's incredibly manageable with medication alone,
actually. it, it responds extremely well.
Some of the, more modern, psychological
treatments, like cognitive behavioral therapy, they
have had some success as well
but not nearly as much as they've had in other areas. This
is very easily fixed and managed with, just taking a pill everyday.
>> do you know of any specific genetic risk that you have
for bipolar? Have you, has your doctor told you about a specific
genetic risk you might have? Or you discovered any
particular gene or genetic risk you might have for bipolar?
>> I've been told, and, I've been told
that it is heritable. That it was likely
in my family, but that doesn't necessarily mean
genetic. So, I wasn't told specifically about genetics.
>> What do you think about the portrayal of
mental health in general, both in media and in
society at large, how we deal with it as a population.
Do you think we take mental health seriously, do you think? It's
portrayed in a meaningful way that gets the right kind of
attention, or do you think we still have some work to do?
>> I definitely believe that in the area of portrayal of mental health, well,
in the area of how the average person thinks of mental health, we have some work
to do, because It's one thing, it's easy to look at someone and say you have
a broken leg, you have a scratch, you've been burned. But when it permeates
the mind, when it permeates the thing
that sitting behind the eyes looking back at
you it's hard to say well, you're an
asshole versus you have an issue. And because
it's so difficult to recognize in the first
place, we tend to, overlook it, minimize it and,
and not give it the type of treatment that we
should. I went through a period actually where insurance was
not quite clear for me, and so I ended up
going to a public clinic to try and get some
assistance with this not long after my diagnosis. And it
was I'm glad the public clinic existed. It was, it
was nice that San, the city of San Francisco who
funded it has decided to make this type of program available.
But it was dehumanizing. I, it was, there're six
slots available on a Saturday. And the doors open
at 9. And you're allowed to, you're allowed to
start lining up at 7 a.m. If you're the seventh
person in line, you will not be seen. And so I got up at 6am and I made my
way down to Soma, which is quasi-sketchy area of
San Francisco. And I wanted in line with other people
who were potentially, violently, mentally ill. And I knew
nothing about it. And for, you know, the first hour
and a half it was completely unsupervised. there was
no one there, there was no guard, there was no
nothing. It was just a bunch of people who
were there. Several people who had had a chronic mental
illness came up and, had gotten into line and then
when the security guard finally came, she recognized a lot
of these individuals as people who apparently came very
frequently. And told them that we already had the correct
number of people online. So basically returning them away.
Even though they were in the correct order online. And
that whole period, it made me recognize that a
lot of these people who were online, I mean, a
lot have been addicted, they now had, were missing their
teeth, they were now And possibly weren't even very educated
to begin with. And these are people who,
certain people, certain areas in America, they consider people
like that to just be leeches on society. To
be people who should be not assisted because they
should just fix their own lives. And i look at them, and I see how lucky I
am to be privileged in many ways, to actually
have been educated, to have a, to have a,
better-than-average mind that sounds really conceited to, to have
sort of some of these self-perceptions and tools and
that I'm able to get help. And I wonder when I see them if they were able to get
help earlier, how different would their lives be. Would
their lives actually have been very productive? Would they have
been able to get back like I've been able
to do? So yeah, I think there are major challenges.
>> If you could say
one thing or one message, generally speaking, to other people who have bipolar
I or II. Or people who may wonder if they do. Maybe haven't been diagnosed.
But have been going through issues themselves. If you could give them a message,
or tell them something. Is there anything, in particular, you would want to say.
>> If I had have a message for somebody who is bipolar II I would
definitely say seek medical assistance. this
is something that responds very well to
treatment. And once you've gotten that
proper treatment, once you've been able to
help yourself out, then you can live a very, very satisfying and happy life.
If you can't afford medical treatment, exercise. It actually goes a long way.